[Applause]
good good
this is Jocko podcast number 160 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willington
good evening echo good evening October
I'm gonna head your way then see you
today though sometimes I wonder why I
should
sometimes you don't seem to care and
that makes me mad brother and then when
I see you it doesn't really make me feel
any better
should it is that what this is for it
doesn't seem to be it actually just
makes me remember the way things used to
be better times it makes me wonder why
things turned out this way
what did I do wrong
should I have done something different
what could I have said
you never let me down ever but now you
won't even talk to me I was looking at
some of the things you wrote to me in
the past I opened up in the email in it
you wrote I feel it again washing over
me the descent into degeneration and
disintegration the smell of filth black
water mixed with blood and gunpowder and
[__] the American soldier covered in
filth eleven months into a 16 month
deployment the insurgents grown men
hiding behind children women wailing
over the dead explosions and screams and
fragments of concrete flying through the
air and frog men entered the scene to
take the hand of the American soldier
and pull him from the Whirlpool to set
his feet back on the rock and speak
words of hope we are the prophets of
doom and destruction we enter an area
and take back the lost pride of America
we redden the stripes blue the field and
make the stars of our tattered and
humiliated battle ensign shine once
again we hold it high we carry a nation
on our shoulders and we bring the enemy
to its knees we do not live in fear of
death or wounding or even worse
rejection by the country we love
I feel my mind coming apart and the old
sleeping animal coming out I tried to
keep it inside but it cannot help but
attend the call to battle when you
originally wrote that to me I thought to
myself yep he's there again where he
should be I knew it wouldn't last
forever but where are you now now you
seem distant in my head I can see you
smile I can hear you laugh but it's only
in my head I was surfing the other day
it was one of those days a good day
solid swell no wind tide was low in the
sky was clear and bright I kept looking
out
toward the outside where you used to sit
and wait for the big set waves I thought
I saw you a couple times but it wasn't
you I heard someone paddling behind me
must be you I thought no nothing no
one's there I'm all alone out here
everything is the same but nothing is
the same everything has changed but
nothing has changed does anything ever
change look at the waves as they
approach the shore each wave formed
through random combinations of wind and
sea and pressure and each one completely
unique and when they break they're gone
forever
but then another one comes behind it and
another one they are all different but
they're all the same and I see some of
the past in the future and I see some of
the future in the past and I begin to
wonder which is which how did I get here
where am I going to end up where are you
I look at some more your writing you are
telling a story writing a story about a
man about God about life about death and
this is what you wrote I am ready to go
he thought to himself but for you I wait
for the appointed time that I will he
said to himself and closed his eyes and
placed his hands on the pages as if
there was some strength there and he
prayed while he prayed he also thought
of past times he breathed in deep and
exhaled deliver us from the evil one he
muttered and he thought of all the
reasons he had no right to say this
prayer at that
he steadied himself opened his eyes and
looked out into the first light of the
morning he saw a face not his own
looking back at him from the window and
disappear but he was not startled this
kind of thing was normal I'm ready for
you he thought to himself while he ran
that morning he did not think about
anything his mind retreated deep into
itself or perhaps it shut down
altogether and he wore no expression he
only looked out at the sea and watched
as the seabirds glided above the
undulating plain of water moving close
above its surface but managing somehow
not to touch it at home he heaved
weights around on a small concrete slab
his routine effortlessly recited and at
the same time painfully undertaken again
without fog or care every morning the
same marking off time until an appointed
end his final rendezvous
that's what you wrote is that what we
are doing here marking off time until an
appointed end my memory plays tricks on
me how many days do I remember how many
days do I actually remember and what
good is a day that I can't remember did
it happen did it exist I want to
remember every day but I can't I let
some of them go and I hate that I want
to remember and re remember the times we
had together
we played songs on the guitar but I
can't hear them anymore they are gone
I can't recreate them I'm not good
enough
can we play them again one more song
here is some more of your writing I am
God's messenger I am a chieftain of
Michael the angel he has granted my
request to help you for it is you who
are doing the bidding of the king we
have heard you many prayers they burned
before us day and night
yes heaven is full of the fragrance of
your prayers and I bring glad tidings
from the Lord of lords he is preparing
his mount to ride here but there is
still more to be done on earth before he
wields his scythes and sword upon it I
bring a message the Lord of lords wants
to help you reap the spirits against
whom you are warring indeed Satan has
asked to have you but we will not let
that happen of course you always have a
choice I have come a long way though I
came when we heard your last prayer you
will not be turned
when I read that it seems obvious even
God was on your side but if God was on
your side how did you end up like this
then how could you do this to me what
about me yeah I know I'm being selfish
but what about me you know what I'm not
going to see you today
you can wait after everything I did for
you after everything we went through
together you can wait
December okay I calm down a little bit I
pride myself in keeping control of my
emotions but I got to admit you had me
breaking down a little bit for a while
you see that you're probably laughing at
me so I'm gonna come up and see you
today is that cool I mean it's supposed
to be cool if nothing else just to say
goodbye I'll bring you a beer or two I
don't even drink anymore but you know
what if you crack one open with me I'll
have one with you
like old times what happened to those
times we were brothers and when we came
home we knew we made it we've made it
man
as crazy it seems I was actually never
that worried about you maybe you were
blessed maybe you were lucky maybe it
was both but whatever it was it worked
you even wrote to me during your next
deployment this is what you wrote
all i interject is my part the firing
and yelling part but the bullets do not
hit me they never hit me they passed
through me like a miracle two days ago
we drove through a village and knocked
all the power lines down and it was
night and the sparks were like incoming
RPGs I wish they were and braced but
they were and the IEDs won't come either
they won't hit me it's like I'm being
protected
you capitalize the P in protected you
believed it was a higher power I can't
rightly argue with you on that but if
that's so true how did this happen why
did this happen where did that
protection go did it abandon you like
you abandon me what am I supposed to do
now you know what I'm not going to see
you today
you can wait
February it's a new year let's try this
again
time heals all wounds they say so we
should be good now right
I should be over at all by now I'll come
see you and at a minimum say goodbye
just just say goodbye just tell you
that's it
no hard feelings don't take it
personally I've decided I'm gonna go
ahead and proceed on down the path
without you
alone and I'm used to being alone no big
deal I kind of like it
but even I have to admit it was nice
nice to have someone to talk to nice to
have someone to talk to without even
talking but look a nod a smile no one is
smiling back anymore no one
sometimes I look up at the night sky
that can approximate a smile I see a
smile in the sunset I don't know why I
try to milk what I can out of everyday I
should be cursing the sunset that sunset
means another day is gone
I should be cursing it but I don't I
take a few minutes when I can and I
watch it good night al Huy good night
chesty good night
stoner maybe there's some relief that
the day is gone is at it that that part
of the race is over and there isn't a
damn thing I can do about it
when my oldest daughter was little we
would watch the sunset over the ocean
when we get the chance and she was at
that age when she was only just starting
to talk she could just say a handful of
words when she wanted a drink of milk
she would say nope when she wanted to go
on the swing
she would say ping when I would throw up
her up in the air and catch her she
would laugh and she would giggle and she
would say the word again
and she and I were sitting on the
seawall it was autumn and the Sun was
leaning towards the south and we watched
and she watched the colors in the sky
red and yellow and orange like fire and
the water ignited then it turned black
and the Sun disappeared into the ocean
and she looked up at me and she said
again she wanted it back
but I couldn't do anything for her I was
powerless I still AM I can't stop the
clock and I can't bring back a day not
one single day not one single minute you
get what you get and that sunset will
keep a man's ego in check especially
when your complete lack of control
disappoints the little angel sitting on
your knee and I can't control this
situation either and that stings and I
don't want to face that I don't want to
say goodbye that can wait you can wait
may springtime rebirth so I'm told
the winter swell fades but the water
warms up the days get longer again I
like that
I look at more of your words they read
he found a sleeping spot happy and
excited with anticipation he thought of
the glory which was to come and he slept
tranquil II and did not dream the blue
midnight sky held no trace of trouble
almost no clouds only a wisp of silver
gray near the moon that seemed to be
something beautiful for the humans below
to look at as an omen that something
good might happen as some kind of sign
that heaven awaited it the good thing
the good thing you wrote what am I
supposed to do with that you set me up
you know with thoughts of the good thing
because there we were you know we were
headed in the right direction toward the
good things when you listen to me things
worked out always right you know it when
you listen to me and you put your damn
heart in check things worked out what's
your problem you listen to your heart
too much you know this let your emotions
get a hold you you know it's true I told
you a thousand times ten thousand times
and you tried to listen and you did
listen sometimes but your heart couldn't
be completely subdued it was too strong
too strong for its own good and yeah I
know I know that's what makes you you
fine
but you should have listened to me you
should have listened and now I am here
and you are there and there is nothing I
can do about it I'm powerless July
full-fledged summer now campfires and
guitar on the regular where you at and
let me ask you something if you aren't
gonna come around then can you just let
me be I don't want you in my head right
now
I don't want to get dragged back every
time I strum a chord
I remember we were traveling up the
coast you may Lazydays surfing by day
playing on the gift boxes at night we
were looking for bigger waves the kind
of waves that get the blood flowing we
found so but what were we really looking
for you know as well as I we were
looking for that thing that moment that
moment when nothing else matters that
moment that is sourced directly from the
battlefield hard to find anywhere else
so we we try and get close to it
jujitsu surfing whatever but it's hard
to replace maybe it can't be replaced
maybe it just is what it is I think I
understood that
I'm not sure you did I was able to
rationalize it figure it out detach from
it see it from the outside before that
trip up the coast you had written me
these words send us we are thirsty for
screams and gore and hell and dirt and
[__] we will hack our way through scores
of bodies form them up in a pile and
burn them so we can kill by the pyre
lights somebody spread the good news
that the killer's teeth are sharp and
their guns are clean and their souls are
dead so no one needs anything but
victory and sacred deference when is is
done you see that was your heart talking
again the same heart that wrapped around
a girl you met the same heart that
brought my kids birthday presents the
same heart that was broken by the loss
of our friends a heart capable of both
devotion and destruction I told you to
let it all go I told you
but I can't control everything I'm still
powerless
September a year has passed or was it
yesterday time seems like a trick but
the trick is on me because it's no trick
at all time does not waver it does not
relinquish it isn't tricky it just is
and it is moving on without judgment and
without mercy and it will keep moving I
am coming up to see you today I have to
I have to say goodbye I can't do it like
this anymore carrying you around in my
head bringing back the past so often
that it's interfering with the present
and the future that's not right that
wasn't part of the deal
I arrived you're still there where I
left you I brought you a beer and some
wax for your board and a guitar pick
even though you play better without one
I already went and saw Mikey and Mark I
save you for last that's the way it is
you were the last to go
and this is the way it always ends here
it always ends like this and I will end
up here too
but I didn't know you'd end up here so
soon here's your beer I'll pour it in
the grass for you I'll put this bar of
surf wax on top of your gravestone the
guitar kick next to it
I read the words etched in that white
granite rock
Seth a stone commander the US Navy
Afghanistan Iraq September 17th 1976
September 30th 2017 Silver Star with oak
leaf cluster Bronze Star Medal with
valor faithful warrior
faithful warrior
I always tell everyone to carry on to
mourn but not to dwell but now I'm
dwelling myself and I know I shouldn't
you know I should
I have thought long and hard about it
and I was going to say goodbye
but I'm not gonna say it
there's no need you're still with me
you're in the ocean and in the sky and
in the earth beneath my feet you're
still with me and I'm good with that
here's one more thing you wrote
I fought the enemy as good as I could I
lost myself but in doing so I found
myself it is a path you have to work
your own one out it is a struggle I have
listened to the truth I am humbled and
mystified by this life we live
that's what you said
and I will tell you this my brother I am
humbled and mystified by this life - and
I am going to keep on living it I can't
stop the Sun sets and I can't bring them
back but I can make them count and that
is what I am going to do I am going to
keep on living and I am going to make it
count
so
here we are and speaking of the living
life and trying to make it count
we're doing this gig here tonight so we
are live we are yeah yeah
[Applause]
we generally call this a rough
transition yeah a little bit yeah yeah
so everyone that's here our first live
podcast thanks for everyone for thanks
to everyone for coming down as I thought
about what to talk about tonight I went
down into a pretty heavy subject and you
know that's part of what this whole
thing is yeah all the people that
reached out to me over the last few
years you know that were able to
overcome some tough situation because of
the podcast and it's the same with me
the same lessons that we've learned from
the podcast from books from having
people on it's the same we get the
benefit of - I get the benefit of that -
and
here we are here we are so thanks for
coming
echo Charles thanks for pressing record
and stop by the way you got it it's it's
a whole it's a little thing and one of
the main things and one of the main
reasons I wanted to do a live podcast is
to actually see everyone and give a
chance for you to see us and for you to
see what we do and what it looks like
and this is pretty much what it looks
like yeah I mean we're sitting in a
small room and we press record and this
is what we do and it's great to have
everyone here and to see your faces and
and I've talked about this before I mean
when I'm recording I'm talking to you
you know I'm talking to the people that
I've heard from over the past few years
I I know what you're listening and even
from day one I wanted to when people put
on their head since I wanted to think
like okay yep this is we're going in
this is it like it's on and I don't want
you to waste your time I don't want to
win I don't want to waste your time so
that's why we're doing this tonight I
thank you all for coming
I also want to take advantage of the
fact that you're here to do some live
Q&A which is very fun for me to do I
enjoy doing it and we did solicit
questions from the ticket sales
did I just escalate that yeah a little
bit you did that for ticket sales and so
we've got some of those questions here
and we'll start off with a couple of
those and then we've got you can bring
the the Q&A lights on and then we're
gonna we got some folks out there
volunteers with microphones and then
once we will open it up and we're gonna
we're gonna racked and
and answer some questions and I know
some of you were waiting to get a
picture of weights get some stuff signed
before this started and we'll finish
this and we'll wrap up that for
everybody here so it's awesome that you
all are sitting here appreciate you
coming down and let's do a little Q&A
yeah yeah yeah it's interesting because
usually we just sort of see the cameras
you know they're on the other side of
the cameras but you just see the get now
it's like oh you actually see the Pew
it's different all right first question
observation will we see them saying like
now I look in the camera like you see
them saying you just saying you see the
people awesome
well let's not blow it anymore leaving
in the more first question we can't edit
out your stuff right yeah yeah all right
Jocko what impresses you the most when
you're considering to work with someone
or hire them to be part of your team
this is a question I get asked all the
time everybody wants to know who to hire
and what I look for and obviously I look
for someone that's humble and I look for
someone that's balanced and really you
know it's one of those things where as
much as you can before you hire someone
get to know them and the advice we give
people a national on front all the time
when they're looking to hire someone is
we say look if you can hire them
temporarily bring them on as a
contractor for 90 days you have to see
them in the environment that they're
actually going into they're gonna be
working in before you know what they're
really gonna be like because just like
going through they screen people like
crazy to go into seal training and it
they can't tell who's gonna make it
who's not gonna make it they just can't
tell and they you you work with people
in the SEAL Teams and you think you know
what they're gonna be like when you're
going to combat but you just can't tell
you can have a decent idea but you just
can't tell and so if you get the
opportunity or the best way to do it is
try and bring people
bored in a temporary manner so you get
to know them better and then once you
know them you can either hire them or
you can get rid of them easily
next question makes sense gaku for a new
entrepreneur or someone new to a
leadership position who is meeting with
their employees or direct report or
direct reports for the first time what
are some key things to address during
that initial conversation as soon as you
meet someone that's going to be working
for you you're immediately making
impression so we want to make a good
impression
we also don't want to go okay it's a
it's a dichotomy because you're
immediately building a relationship with
them but you can't go overboard and be
all buddy-buddy with them that's why I
followed the hackworth model and I
actually took that to the next level
hackworth wouldn't like laugh and joke
around with the troops for six weeks I
upped that to eight weeks because I'm a
little bit more hardcore yeah so you but
but one thing that's good out of the
gate is put out some brief general
guidelines like some some of the most
broad guidance that you can possibly
give which is hey look here's what's
important to me we're going to do a
great job we're gonna work hard and this
is our mission and this is what we're
gonna focus on and that's it you don't
need to come out of the gate trying to
show everyone that you're the man you
don't need to do that guess what
you're the boss you actually de facto
are the man so don't run around and try
and prove yourself out of the gate get
to know them
let that relationship build over time
and that's we're gonna end up in the
best situation that you sort of did that
to me even as friends like this like
here yeah good to meet you here's you
good to meet you yeah eight weeks just
like that next question
yeah yeah well it's funny too because
now when I meet people like tonight I'm
all nice to everyone now yeah yeah you
changed really plain - yeah but if I was
gonna be like getting in the game with
them and somehow yeah yeah yeah
eight-week probationary Jocko period who
are some of the well-known leaders today
who you believe best exemplify extreme
ownership be it in politics military or
business military you know obviously I
like I like mattis a lot but matter of
fact I'd like mattis yeah I
general Kelly same thing yep and
McMaster same thing all those guys are
awesome Colonel MacFarland or general
McFarland who just retired who I worked
before in Ramadi who is awesome so
though there's a lot of really good
military examples the business examples
there's a Mullaly who turned around
forward there's a great book called
American icon and it's a great
leadership book I actually was gonna
cover it but I never did because it's
hard to cover books about business
compared to books about combat but it's
a really good book American icon of
great ownership great attitude and
politics
this was a super hardened one but then I
just thought Oh Dan Crenshaw and really
just the way Dan since he's taking
position like he's just doing a great
job it's very very cool to see so yeah
there you go
what else go to for hijack oh and echo I
recently read the book marine the life
of chesty puller and in the book chesty
references and the unnecessary loads of
administrative paperwork that was
required to be prepared for the military
I also recently remember on it on a
recent podcast you recalling a situation
in Ramadi where your platoon leaders
we're not thrilled to fill out required
paperwork I'm a squad sergeant in a
prominent American
in police department and I'm
experiencing the same dilemma the
micromanaging and oversight is extreme
and up to n it's taking a toll on the
morale of the officers citywide the
tedious paperwork and constant
micromanaging is preventing good cops
from being proactive I feel like the job
quote unquote
has changed beyond recognition I'd
appreciate your advice on how to
approach the [__] paperwork and
increase the morale of my cops thank you
for your time okay so what would I do in
this situation first of all I am going
to be awesome at the paperwork I'm gonna
do it so well that because if you blow
off the paperwork then you go to your
boss and say the paperwork sucks and
it's not any good the guy looks at you
and says oh you know what you don't even
know how to do the paperwork how do you
know this how do you know if it's hard
or not so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
do I'm gonna start building a case
that's what I'm gonna do so I'm gonna do
the paperwork I'm actually gonna log
down how many hours I put into the
paperwork I'm gonna follow that
paperwork and see where it goes and see
if anyone actually reads it right cuz if
I can go to my boss and say hey I spent
28 hours a week filing this paperwork
and no not one single person read it and
then you take the manpower of everyone
in the department and then what you do
is you actually build a case when you go
in to talk to the boss you should have a
full magazine of ammunition to combat
this paperwork that you're being forced
to do you have to be able to explain it
to them in a rational logical manner and
you can't you can't make any headway
against your boss if you are trying to
fight from the low ground the low ground
is why don't really turn into paperwork
and I don't really do the paperwork and
I think the paperwork is crap then
they're looking down on you what are you
talking about how are you dare you say
that you don't even do it you don't even
know what you're doing you got to get on
the high ground how do you get on the
high ground you get all that stuff done
to the best your ability you log down
the hours it takes you get your whole
little team doing it and you tell your
whole team hey look I know
painful right now everyone in this squad
everyone in this platoon is gonna do all
this we're gonna log down what it takes
because I am gonna bring a solid case up
the chain of command of where we need to
limit this paperwork this is a long war
situation you know how long it took to
build up all that paperwork it took
years it took 20 years 30 years for that
to happen I used to joke about the
marine the Navy the SEAL Teams the range
our range procedures are super loose we
go out there and we shoot like crazy and
do all kinds of really dynamic things
and we sometimes go to a Marine Corps
range it was like everything was super
tight and I would tell my guys I'd say
look that's because that happened over
years one mistake happens how do you
stop that mistake from happening again
put a rule in place that stops it
another mistakes happen another mistake
happens put another rule in place
another mistake happens put a piece of
paper to stop it from happening again
and eventually you end up with a range
that's barely even usable so that's what
happened in this department
there was little things that happen over
time and they build and they build upon
themselves and the next thing you know
you can't even recognize what your
actual job was so we have to it so that
took 20 years to happen you're not gonna
undo it overnight and you're definitely
not gonna undo it from the low ground
you have to get the high ground you have
to be a performer if you're not a
performer you have no say do your job do
it well fight the long war
[Applause]
I'm all of a sudden thinking like maybe
we need one of those little applause
tracks you know when I answer a question
yeah yeah when it's good man it's good
but next question what book has had the
biggest impact on you and is a must read
[Applause]
yeah about face a quirk thanks for
coming
welcome to the club yeah all right
good one okay next good morning was that
like a raw gold band just lets the crowd
sing the chorus if you did not join the
military what do you think you'd be
doing right now
I I think I would have ended up either
in the police department or a
firefighter that's what I think I would
have done if I couldn't have gotten into
the military that's probably what I
would end up doing why just because I
had the urge to serve and do something
physical and do something where I'm
helping protect people I think that's
why yeah so I know there's a lot of cops
and firefighters here so thanks for what
you do
[Applause]
what is the relationship between
humility and vulnerability the
relationship between humility and
vulnerability okay interesting and
there's an interesting dynamic that you
get going on when you when you're humble
okay so let's think about what happens
when you're humble when you're humble
you expose your vulnerabilities but
what's cool is when you expose your
vulnerabilities they become less
vulnerable so that's why being humble is
a win yeah because if I'm taking over a
position and I don't know how to do one
of the jobs if I hide it it's it's
haunting me and it's a weakness because
as soon as it gets exposed I'm gonna
look like you know weak and a loser but
if I have a vulnerability and I'm humble
enough to expose my vulnerability and
say hey you know what guys I haven't
actually done this before my old unit we
didn't never did this and I don't know
how to do it can I get some help here
there I'm being humble I'm exposing my
vulnerability and all of a sudden it's
not a vulnerability anymore because the
because my team actually knows it and
guess what then I get to practice and
learn about the thing that was making me
vulnerable yeah so making yourself
vulnerable is fine and if you want to
kill your vulnerabilities you have to be
humble enough to expose them voluntarily
voluntarily exposing your
vulnerabilities is infinitely better
than hiding them and letting them be
uncovered by them you know teams that's
what it is it's it's it's animals hmm
like everyone else in your platoon if
you have a vulnerability and you hide it
and then eight
like they're coming at you
with daggers with knives and they're
gonna so if you say hey this is the
situation expose those vulnerability be
humble enough to do that you'll be in a
much better position yeah and it seems
like the leader like if you're the boss
and you're trying to make like oh yeah I
know everything and then like how you
said they find it you look way more
stupid like in the beginning it feels
like you looks more stupid in the
beginning I would think anyway like law
I'm the bar supposed to know all this
stuff yeah I think the key point of that
is way more stupid you know what I look
like that I don't think so yeah anyway
all right I'm gonna go back to this
other one three dinner guests living or
dead and why three dinner guests living
or dead Mark Lee Mike Mansoor Ryan Joe
[Applause]
how did you get the nickname Jocko I
answered this on Facebook live not fully
that I didn't know fully anyways before
I was born my dad wanted me to be a jock
my dad's name is John
my dad's nickname is John no my dad
wanted me to be a jock my mom calls my
dad John oh my dad said I hope he's a
jock
my mom said a jock oh I don't the yeah I
don't think he said that whole thing ya
know that's the deal
and then actually when I said that my
mom said actually my dad was nicknamed
John oh not by her but by his family
because he was named after his uncle
whose name was John Bogle for for
something like that yeah that's okay
yeah man goes deep there you go
a question for Jocko do you teach your
wife about being strategic and how open
is she to how open is she there having
her husband be her teacher that's a good
one that's a that's a yes that's a good
one for whom for what for ruining my
life it's it's a good one for me
fish okay first of all let's assess this
hmm how many people just people we're
not even talking spouses how many people
are just super open to being taught like
if I was like let me teach you a little
something
yeah you don't mean like that's that
already starts off on a bad foot in
because it implies that I know something
you don't know it can help you yeah
you're you're you're inferior to me you
lack the supreme knowledge that I have
yeah clearly I must instruct you in a
strategic ways right mmm okay and if
that's not offensive to someone it is
offensive to my wife
so do I sit around and you know try and
teach my wife you know here's the deal
here's the deal
when we're dealing with our kids I
absolutely do this now that I think
about it you know I'll say to my wife
hey listen oh the boys doing this and
you're trying to do this don't do that
all you're doing is you know it's oh he
want he wants to get all crazy cool
let's do this you're trying to combat I
just tell this when when the kids were
really small because she's super nice
and concerned and wants to make things
right and wants to win arguments which
one you're trying to win in law a
logical argument with a four-year-old it
doesn't work it doesn't work and I'd say
look you're arguing logic with a
four-year-old so I think there's an
appropriate time to do it you have to be
careful that you're not trying to you
know be the superior human yeah Oh mr.
strategy you want to teach me something
about cats yeah so take it easy and all
that being said I do have strategic
conversations with my wife about the
family team right like we're a business
like your house and your family as a
business you have income you have
expenditures you have long-term
strategic goals so those kind of things
we talked about and you know I'm the one
that sort of is usually saying hey what
about this strategic goal what are you
doing over here what do you wanna do
that so we have those conversations but
not so much me saying how but me you
know us figuring out where we're going
together life
does she ever like teach you how to be
strategic in any way like be more
sensitive or anything like that bro you
serious
no actually my cool thing about my wife
is she knows me really well and accepts
there's a whole deal yeah she accepts
the shortfalls
she knows that she got what she got she
rolled the dice hey sorry yeah alright
next question can you share how someone
that is introverted and has social
anxiety can become a leader I mean first
of all if you've got social anxiety you
need to go through that exposure therapy
which is what I wrote about in way the
warrior kid that I didn't know I was
writing about I didn't it was an actual
psychological methodology until Jordan
Peterson was explaining to me that well
what you do is someone in this situation
is you give them small explosions like
oh that's what happens in a way of the
warrior kid yeah I'm smarter than I
thought so you can do the same thing
with this social anxiety you know you
start talking in front of small groups
you grow you get out and hang out with
people and you continue to do that until
you get more comfortable so you can you
can sort of overcome that and it's the
same thing with being introverted now
there there are leaders that are more
introverted but what you have to do is
you have to bring people on to your team
to complement that area where you're a
little bit weak so if if you're a leader
guess what you have to do you have to
communicate to other human beings and
sometimes you have to communicate
communicate to other human beings in
large groups that's what happens that's
what a leader does sure sometimes it can
be on the phone sometimes could be on
the email sometimes it can be in radio
over the radio but there's times where
you're gonna have to communicate to the
people that you're leading so if you're
super introverted and uncomfortable with
that and it's a challenge
gonna have to overcome that challenge
yes you can get better at it through
practice but some people are not gonna
ever get a really comfortable bit some
people are never gonna get really
comfortable talking in front of a group
and so what what you do in that
situation is you bring someone in your
team that is really good at it and then
when it's time to address the troops you
you know you as the leader stand up and
say here's the two things I'm worried
about on this operation here's where
we're heading and now Bill's gonna brief
you on the details of the plan and
that's fine because Bill's a loudmouth
the bills gonna get up there and
communicate really clearly and that's
gonna be great and you still gave enough
as the figurehead and as the leader of
the organization that people go okay yep
we heard from Jocko you know he put out
the word he didn't say much doesn't even
seem like he has to we we hear where
he's coming from
so you just have to build a team that's
gonna complement your weaknesses and you
know generally if you're introverted
well that means you're good at some
other thing that that loudmouth isn't
good at right the loudmouth other groups
go in the front door kick it down and he
doesn't have any sort of tactical sense
of how to run an operation smoothly so
you come up with a good plan and then
you brief it's a bill Loudmouth bill and
then you say bill we're gonna brief the
troops and then you make it happen so
you have to do a little bit of both you
have to improve your personal skills
which you can do through exposure and
practice don't get up and talk about
things that you don't know get up and
talk about things that you do know that
you're are comfortable with and you
practice and while you're practicing
while you're getting it better at that
you also build a team where you
complement your own weaknesses and we
all have leadership weaknesses and you
got to build teams that can complement
that
agree
I'm glad next question how can one guide
or lead a leader above you especially
when your many links away on the chain
of command or many links went down the
chain of command oh so you want to guide
a leader that's far away from you in the
chain of command yeah yeah you gotta
build a relationship with that person
that's what you got to do in fact
leadership is about building trust and
building relationships with people and
Trust is leadership and leadership is
trust and relationships are trust and
relationships are leadership
these are like the the trifecta of
becoming a good leader you build trust
with people you build relationships and
in a situation like this if I have know
if you and I don't know each other very
well and I come up to you and say hey I
think you should do this what's your
reaction right if you just approach
someone that you don't have a
relationship with and then you start
telling them how to run things that
that's offensive that's offensive to
like most human beings I have to I have
to get to know you I have to see what
kind of approach is gonna work for you
because you might be the kind of person
if I know you a little bit we like you
know I'm really working on my leadership
what do you think I could do better
that's great then we open the door and
we can move forward you might be the
kind of person that I have to flank you
might be the kind of person that you
won't listen to me but I say oh you
should check out this book that I read
or whatever there's ways to do it but to
look at a target and know how you're
going to attack the target without
knowing anything about it without having
an any intelligence on it that's not
gonna be effective so we have to
actually gather some intelligence about
the target we have to and the way we do
that is by building a relationship with
by getting to know that person once you
know the person then you can start to
infuse and shift and mold and sculpt and
influence the way that they lead you
have to build that relationship
to kick things off next question I'm not
in the military nor am i a firefighter
or law enforcement I'm an air traffic
controller here in the New York area and
I found myself in several leadership
positions without within our union since
I read extreme ownership I've tried to
implement this and in the ideals that
come with it overall I believe it's been
a success and of course still a work in
progress
specifically the communication aspect of
ensuring our people know why are we
doing why are we are doing something and
how it affects them as it has been the
biggest influence and game-changer in my
opinion unions typically come
hand-in-hand with what about me
attitudes and we definitely have that
within our ranks this is something I've
been trying to tackle with both new air
controllers new controllers and older
ones and I think I'm making headway
slowly but surely thanks to you in life
my question is this have you ever had
direct experience dealing with unions in
this particular mindset is there any
advice you can have you have specific to
labor unions that could make this more
effective yeah we well we work with
businesses all the time and we certainly
work with businesses that are involved
with or that that either are unionized
or partially unionized and yeah this is
something that can be very very common
and the reason it can become very very
common is because the union is is an
organization right and the company the
the corporate the headquarters is a
separate organization and so what
happens is as we let these two elements
grow they they tend to grow apart and
they tend to start looking out for
themselves and that becomes problematic
it becomes problematic in any
organization where you've got the union
on one side and what the union starts
looking out for is what's good
them and what corporate is looking out
for what headquarters looking out for is
what's good for them and what happens is
we stop talking to each other and we and
what we fail to realize is that both
those entities have a common goal
they have a common goal and the more we
work together to achieve that common
goal the better off both entities will
be so what this boils down to and the
where I would focus step number one and
this this is a long fight this is a long
war is trying to make sure that the
Union side because you're talking about
from your position in the Union the
Union side understands how working with
corporate headquarters how working with
them will benefit the individuals in the
Union in the long run so and a great
book to read about this is that book I
mentioned earlier with Mullaly American
icon and and what he you know what he
told the union's was hey listen I get it
you want your hourly wage to be seventy
six dollars an hour you want to take
care of the Union that's awesome let me
tell you what's gonna happen in 18
months if we keep paying that we're not
gonna have a company anymore here's the
numbers here's how it's gonna work
and they lower down their hourly rate to
55 dollars an hour that's a huge cut and
you can imagine the Union thinkin oh
that's we lost we lost but Mullaly did a
great job of saying no we lose if we
don't come together we lose if we don't
try and achieve our actual mission of
the mission that we're all focused on
which is making great cars and being a
profitable company so same thing here
make sure that the areas that overlap
the common mission make sure that
everyone understands how achieving the
common mission benefits
both parties next question I've been a
police officer guys wrote some long
questions for Echo Charles well in that
he's been studying him for four hours
I've been a police officer for about
four years I consider myself to be
proactive and try to get after it every
day much like many of my brother and
sister law enforcement officers recently
I switched to a bigger agency with a
with a bit of a different mission I
still try to be as proactive and as
thorough as I can in everything that I
do but I've noticed that many of the
frontline supervisors in this agency
want officers to be reactive rather than
proactive the supervisor in particular
has told me to stop working so hard and
get salty suggesting that I lower my
morale the question is how do I build a
relationship with these supervisors
while still being proactive and working
hard so this is what I did when I got to
SEAL team 1 I was this guy right here I
was fired up I was hey oh we're doing an
obstacle course today cool I'm gonna
wear my rucksack with a 40 pound sandbag
in it and all the guys that were older
were you know looking at me like dude
pump the brakes
and you know of course what did I think
those cars are part of core those guys
are weak that's what I was thinking and
then you know I thought to myself okay
how can i how can I have influence over
them how can I have influence over the
platoon that I'm in can I have influence
over the platoon that I'm in if everyone
that's in my platoon doesn't like me no
can you if everyone in my platoon
doesn't like me because I'm super
hardcore then are they gonna steer it
all in my direction no the answer's no
the answer is no in fact they're gonna
isolate me in fact I'm gonna have no
influence over my platoon and that's
that's a horrible thing so what did I do
did I just go okay chord it looks like
Donuts is the deal now I didn't do that
at all but I conformed but I conformed
and people think oh that's weak you
shouldn't conform look you are not the
priority you as an individual are not
the priority in a co platoon you're not
the the priority is the platoon the
priority is the mission and if we're
gonna execute a mission we need to be
very tight as a team so if I put my
personality above the unity of the team
I'm hurting our capability of
accomplishing the mission especially if
I realize that guys need to train a
little bit harder and instead of
actually doing something that's gonna
move them in that direction they reject
me and now I'm outside the the
Brotherhood the circle and now I haven't
moved them in any right direction and
also now there's one guy that's in
really good shape me and everyone else
is
going in the other direction and I have
no influence over them that that's just
terrible the mission is the most
important thing in order to most
effectively execute the mission we have
to have the best possible team in order
to have the best possible team we have
to have trust and relationships inside
the team if I violate that I'm taken
away from the team I'm taking away from
our mission capability now of course if
there's someone that's grossly out of
shape or out of standards yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna try and tighten that person up
but again if someone's completely out of
standards and all I do is attack them
what's their reaction it's to step away
from me to reject me but if I see if I
say hey man you know I know you got a
lot of experience and you know I'm 19
and I just got a bud so I'm in pretty
good shape but like can can you teach me
some of the tactics that you know and
all of a sudden I'm building a
relationship with them and then I say
hey do you want to go for a little a
little job with me after work and you
know that guy's done eight deployments
and he's tired and years old but he
wants to be back in shape because we all
want to be in shape and he goes okay a
short one
and we're moving in the right direction
so that's what you needed to be you have
to you have to back off a little bit you
have to find balance and you have to
focus on the team and it's better to
have the whole team it's better to have
20 people that move a little bit in the
right direction then have one person by
themself that's going on the right
direction and everyone else is going in
the wrong direction so that's what you
need to do take the sandbag out of your
rucksack a little bit and you know I ran
with jungle boots on I did all this
stuff and it didn't take me very long to
realize I was not doing the right thing
not making my team stronger
I was isolating myself and stopped it so
this guy he should like what start
acting just a little bit salty or you
know or you know lower his morale
appearance a little bit like they're
kind of fit in so to speak yeah do you
want to be part of the team yeah if
you're not part of the team you don't
have any influence if you don't have any
influence you can't move the team in the
right direction if you can't move the
team in the right direction the team is
less mission capable that's what you're
there for
yeah is to make the team more mission
capable every moment that you don't do
that you're doing something wrong so yes
you don't have to show up I mean just
imagine I was a new guy at SEAL team 1
people still we show up to run the o
course the old course is the obstacle
course is a really hard obstacle course
and I show up with a rock sack on with a
40 pound sandbag in it as a new guy yeah
you know of course got people like oh
that's fired up but people were like
okay
oh you're oh you're you're 19 years old
and you just got out of buds yeah
whatever makes we don't like you yeah
so that's gonna like steering like a big
van right you can't just start making
big turns with a big otherwise that
thing's gonna gonna tip over a little
bit so you saying no you gotta like you
can't if there you got a you got to go
slow is what I'm saying okay you guys
understand anyway next question sure
apparently apparently the fan thing was
a hit it was correct that's uh somebody
that didn't understand it and so we
understood man it was correct yes
exactly same thing outstanding anyway my
wife and I have four young boys ages
between ages three and seven we're both
running successful busy careers my
question is how do you forge a
meaningful connected relationship that
instills discipline and leadership with
your kids while balancing today's
demanding 24/7 corporate environment
here's a couple things make time you
have to make time you have to make time
where you're not looking at your phone
they're not looking at your emails you
have to set a good example and and I
think the most important thing here for
kids age three to seven you have to make
sure that they understand that what
you're doing what you're doing and why
you're doing it they have to understand
look you know this house we live in we
have to pay money for this house that we
live in you know the food that we eat we
have to pay money for that and in order
for us to have a secure future where we
can still have a house and we can still
have food we need to make sure that we
have money for the future that's why mom
and dad work so hard it doesn't mean
that we wouldn't love to sit around and
play with you guys all day we would love
to do that in every chance we get we're
gonna do it but we have to be able to
pay for the things we have and we have
to be able to pay for our future and
that's why we're working so hard right
now so we can have more freedom and more
time with you in the future so they have
to understand why you're doing what
you're doing and I'll add this so do you
so do you you have to assess why you are
working so much that you're taking time
away from your family if you're working
so much and taking time away from your
family so that you can get the Mercedes
s-class
instead of the Lexus ask yourself is
that why you're doing it and what has
more value the s-class or the dance
recital keep yourself in check yeah
makes sense to any you kind of gotta
tell the truth to yourself cuz you know
like you could answer the email later or
at another time not dinner time or
whatever you know yeah you kind of got
to be truthful that's what I found
anyway helps
that's why you don't return my emails on
time next question was there time during
your service in the teams that stood out
above the rest and when you mind sharing
a brief story not before heard on your
podcast
well obviously the time in the teams was
being ant asking a bruiser of beating
the battle or mati that's pretty
straight forward something that I
haven't I don't think I've talked about
on the podcast but it it definitely is
something that I remember very clearly
and that is when when SEAL team five
came in to take over for us and so this
was in October of 2006 and SEAL Team 5
attacking it from SEAL team five came in
to take over for us and we're doing the
turnover with them meaning we're
explaining to them the battlespace and
it takes a couple days for all of them
to arrive they arrive at bits and pieces
and so we're doing the turnover but once
they were all there I did a turnover
brief with them the whole group and as a
matter of fact marcus luttrell was in
this group and this was after he had
gone through what he'd gone through in
you know I just saw Marcus the other day
and we were talking about this
I couldn't believe he was in Ramadi
after what he went through and this was
not long after there he was in Ramadi
as a platoon leading petty officer and
it was his group of guys and I remember
one thing I just I just remember was
looking at them and I was telling them
you are going to take casualties and
[Music]
that it's sort of like that thing you
see in the movies or I've talked about
it read it in books about Vietnam where
you had guys that were coming in country
and they got new camouflage uniforms on
and they're all clean-cut and there's
the guys that are getting ready to go
home
and those guys at that time seals
deploying into a situation you seals
deployment situations they're kind of
unknown at least up until this point it
was like okay well we're going we're
gonna do missions we don't know how bad
it's gonna be it might be bad it might
not be that sort of was this standard
those guys that were coming into Ramadi
that relieved us Ramadi they knew and
the senior enlisted guys are one of my
very good friends those guys knew 100%
they went to Mike montsouris funeral and
then got on a plane and came over they
knew a hundred percent and so for me I
won't forget looking at this group of
guys that were about to start a
six-month deployment and telling them
you are going to take casualties and
that was just a blunt honest truth and
they did take casualties they didn't
lose anyone they had no one killed but
they took some very very severe
casualties and did a great job great
group of guys but that was a harsh
reality to walk into for sure
Roger do one more of these questions
before the life will go live the people
what was your first combat mission and
what was your role so 2003 I deployed to
Baghdad as a seal platoon commander and
the senior enlisted guy of my task unit
was already in Baghdad waiting for us
and this guy is an incredible guy
just as a matter of fact his wife tells
him and me that were soul mates she's
jealous but anyways this guy just an
incredible guy but he had been on the
ground for a while and he'd done the
push-up in into Baghdad with the Marines
and then he'd come home and then he was
back over and so he was waiting for us
and he was it was my platoon we show up
and I remember we hit the ground we I
don't even know how long we'd been there
for but it wasn't long this might have
been like the night we got there and
there was mortar teams that were more
during our base and they had been for a
few days and so this guy a couple
mortars went I think anyways whatever
happened he comes in like you're taking
your guys out right now you got to take
your guys out and go and see if you can
find you where these things launch from
and I was I was sort of not ready for
that you know we've been there for four
hours but you're taking your guys out
and I'm you know what I said Roger that
and you know I talked to him later like
later that night he goes yeah I was just
trying to get you outside the wire and
get some and I was like how about you
give me a heads-up next time so that was
it
I was just running that little vehicle
thing and we went out look for bad guys
we didn't find any and came home but
that was the first kind of exposure
outside the wire in Baghdad not a very
exciting story sorry there we go
alright so we got some folks running
around with microphones and does anyone
have a does anyone have any questions
okay see a couple hands anyways I'm
gonna take this thing off so I can sort
of move around and see you and our mic
people I'll point to you we'll find
somebody all right let's go you right
there black sweatshirt I was just trying
to get him to call on me but he wouldn't
wait until he took your order so you got
a good team here so you were talking
about child-rearing before so not me
personally but no you had to you were
cornered Oh any thoughts about having a
child rearing book come out like a team
child-rearing book you mean how to raise
kids well yeah
Charlie berry yeah I mean it maybe Matt
maybe this is a bad idea no no no I'll
tell you what there I wrote a couple
books one's called way the warrior kid
and one's called mark marks mission I
read them okay yeah I mean the the
amount of people that have come back to
me and said like as a dad as a mom thank
you for writing this book because every
time I read it I learned now that means
that I'm basically saying hey you need
to learn you need to pull parse the
lessons out of here
so perhaps I could be making more
straight forward and also hey as I'm the
perfect parent by any stretch but one
thing that's good about putting the
ideas on paper is I would start to
clarify things myself and you start
looking at I would start looking at
mistakes that I made and say okay here's
a clear mistake I didn't really
recognize it before but now that I'm
detached I'm looking back at it so yeah
not a bad idea
yeah finances everything just how to
discuss with your kids like all of these
things are really important topics
and I think the extreme ownership
perspective could be a great addition
awesome Thank You Ohio question over
here you he's leaving it I like to come
prepared
good evening chuckle good evening what
lesson do you wish you'd have learnt
earlier in life that you now know it is
discipline equals freedom I mean that is
the thing that that when I connected
that together in my head that the fact
that that applies to absolutely
everything that's the biggest lesson
that I wish I would have learned earlier
in life and if I would have figured that
out then I would have been doing a lot
better and I would have done a lot
better I would have been a lot better of
a person the thing that I tried to tell
kids I try and tell them that for sure
the other thing that I think kids miss
is kids and this is something that I
completely missed as a kid the actions
that you take now affect your future
that sounds so obvious but when you're
14 you just think no nothing I you know
my life is only another 20 minutes so
what I'm doing right now doesn't really
matter so when I talk to kids I try and
explain to him the discipline equals
freedom and then I try to explain to
them that what you're doing right now
really will have an impact to where you
are in the future and I don't know if
you listen to that podcast that I do it
the warrior kid podcast that I did
number 19 about my friend Jeff and I
talked about it on the adult podcast as
well but you know it's a classic story I
had a best friend when I was little and
we separated friendship not we were
still friends but we drifted apart
he started getting into party and
getting into drugs and all that and I
didn't and his trajectory in life just
went down and I joined the Navy which
was great and it put me on
good path or almost involuntarily but he
ended up he ended up killing himself and
you know he was drugs it was alcohol and
it was just bad but while I was going
through buds he killed himself and when
I tried to explain to the kids on the
warrior kid podcast is like the
decisions that the little decisions that
you make
they matter they add up and you have to
connect those dots otherwise you don't
know where you're gonna end up and it
might be bad cool you got your hand up
quick bro good job how you doing how you
doing Jocko so first I want to say thank
you for being here and continuing to
inspire us all I really appreciate it so
little backstory I'm currently a
detective in a police department in New
Jersey and sitting number one on the
sergeant's list looking to get promoted
about March or April so my question is
I'm gonna be the youngest sergeant in
the department and not with a lot of
experience now I've never had an issue
in the department doing pretty well and
as soon as that list came out and I was
number one the tension just rose I'm
gonna look at this kid less than five
years on the job you know in his 20s and
they already want to see me fail before
I even got to the position so I'm trying
to mentally prepare myself in that role
when I already know that it's coming
against me so what's your best advice
for someone that is gonna be you know in
this position of see I always look at
every position as a leadership position
but now structurally I'm gonna be their
supervisor so what's your best advice to
to me going into that situation yeah
this is the same exact situation that
military officers get put into military
officers in the SEAL Teams and the
Marine Corps and the army and the Navy
you're a kid that comes out of college
you had zero experience and you get put
in charge of a department on a ship or
you get put in charge of a platoon and
all of a sudden you're a guy with zero
experience and you got a platoon chief
that's been in for 16 years that's
that's the way it works and so I've had
have this conversation over and over
again and what we're gonna do is number
one we're not gonna act like we know
everything even if you do know more even
if you have things more figured out than
these guys if you go in there and act
like it guess what they're gonna do
they're gonna reject you who is this
young whippersnapper Young Buck thinks
he knows everything he doesn't know
about this he doesn't know about that
they'll sabotage you to make you look
bad but if you go in there and you're
humble I'm not talking about being a
pushover I'm not talking about being
weak but I'm gonna lean towards being
humble I'm gonna lean towards listening
to what they have to say I'm gonna lean
towards saying hey you know I've never
handled a case like this before do you
have any perspective you could even help
me out with this instead of hey this
case is mine let me show you how it's
gonna be that right there you're taking
a relationship in a negative direction
we want it we want to we want to build a
team and we want them to we want to get
their respect how do you how do we get
their respect we get we actually get
respect as crazy sound we get respect by
by being humble
so if echo if echo is working for me I
show up he's more experienced than me
and I show up and I say all right here's
what we're doing here's how we're doing
this mission here's how it's gonna be my
way and I think he knows what's up now
he knows he sees on the boss what's he
actually thinking who's this idiot
that's had the job for three days and he
thinks gonna he's gonna tell me what to
do and he's gonna he's gonna resist it
he's gonna sabotage he's gonna and we're
gonna have a bad relationship but if I
come in and say hey echo really great to
meet you you know I'm just checking in
here I was looking at your I was like
checking out your your record you've
been here for a long time man you'd
really nailed some big cases that's
awesome I'm looking forward to working
with you I'm looking forward to learning
a lot from you and boom what's his
attitude towards me now hey this kids
pretty humble again I'm not coming in
saying I don't know anything
can you please you know show me the way
oh master no I'm not talking about that
but just a nice respectful humble way of
treating people study show up earlier
than they do know the nomenclature that
you're supposed to know
ask good questions listen to the
feedback and here i've talked about this
in the podcast if he comes up with a
plan and i think i have a better plan
but he's got a plan that's that's pretty
solid
whose plan am i gonna pick i'm gonna
pick his plan I'm not gonna force my
plan down his throat
it makes our relationship go backwards
it makes him think that he needs to
compete with me I wanted to cop the heck
oh this is your plan you come up with it
you make it happen
echo always jokes music I know you do
this stuff to me and he's like and it
still works and I do you know I do it's
like hey if he can come up with a plan I
would rather we execute his plan because
then he cares more about it
it's his so stay humble listen work hard
preciate it thanks for your service
brother thank you
front row shot it up quit right here you
got that thing up quick a game first of
all Joe thank you for being out here in
New York it's great to finally see you
live I just want to get respect if you
already elaborated some on communicating
as a family you said even put some more
content out regarding that stuff hold on
a second bro my hearings not great
slow down hit it with me again high
quick and simple top three rules on
raising kids from ages three to nine
really getting that sort of attitude
instilled while they're still young so
not about the family like dynamic not
about managing just the kids attitudes
yeah it's with kids first of all you got
to remember and this is the hardest
thing for parents to deal with is your
kid is not going to be who you want them
to be they're just not they're humans
and they have their if that was the
truth all of my kids would be the same
type of kid and they would all you know
you could just here's what they all do
they're not they're not your kids are
gonna be different and your kids gonna
be different from you they might be a
little bit better than you at some
things they might be worse than you to
other things so what you have
to do is first of all get that idea out
of your head that being said you can
definitely provide guidance and you can
definitely put them in guide them in the
right direction but what you don't want
to do is make every decision for them
what you don't want to do is only let
them do what you tell them to do they've
got to learn to make decisions otherwise
they can't go into the world and fend
for themselves they've got to suffer
consequences of their bad decisions
otherwise they can't fend for themselves
in the world so you have to I've said
this before you have to you have to like
let them brush up against the guardrails
of failure you have to let them try they
want you you have to let them spill the
milk and the more you make or allow them
to do for themselves the better human
beings they're gonna be the more that
you do for them and force on them and
impose on them the less they're gonna
know for themselves and the more they're
gonna rebel against the values that
you're putting forth to them again it's
a dichotomy and I'm not saying hey let
your kids do whatever you whatever they
want when they go outside that box
there's given a nice big box when they
go outside of that you've got to bring
them back in and you gotta explain to
them why you're bringing them back in
they got to understand that there's the
reason they're not allowed to play in
this area is because there's bad people
there or there's danger there it's not
just because I said so
so you develop these relationships with
your kid you guide them but you don't
direct them and you let them be as much
of a leader as they can be and that's
the best thing you can do for me thank
you can I add one more thing
to that which actually Jocko opened my
eyes to this and it like like your kids
are always watching you like always what
so if you're yelling at mom or yelling
at people on the phone or I don't know
doing stuff you're doing stuff that you
don't want them to do you can say hey
don't do this they'll be like cool but
once they kind of get the opportunity
they're like I guess this is kind of how
because dad does it especially with the
yelling thing and losing like the how do
you deal with stress and stuff that's
brother they'll jump right on that
that's that's what I really noticed when
actually when he opened my eyes to it I
was like aha okay you know what you know
sometimes you get kids in or your kids
how many kids you have oh okay all right
well you're planning ahead okay right
there you go we'll keep this in mind
then because a lot of the times you're
like oh you're three year older you'd be
like dang where did they how did they
pick that up I didn't teach them that
and the thing is you probably will have
taught them that just by doing it on
your own you know yeah this so they're
always watching you so make that help me
I think a lot type to kids but tighten
your game up a little bit around the
kids
let's see really tall hand back there
you thank you so a very specific example
then my son he's three I would love for
him to get into Brazilian jiu-jitsu just
like me which I also got into thanks to
you two gentlemen thank you very much so
how do I encourage him without pushing
him without you know just getting him
into it really you have to make it fun
you have to make it fun and it is much
better for it to be fun once a week then
for them to hate it three times a week
the kid that hates it three times a week
and you think I'm doing him a favor
or I'm doing her a favor cuz I got her
in there whether she likes it or not
she's three years old bro
the best possible thing you can do is
not make them train jiu-jitsu right now
it's make them enjoy jiu-jitsu right now
I did not do this well with my kids
I didn't it's horrible when Mike were my
de specially my daughter's my daughter
who they were very young it was
jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu we were
doing they were doing jiu-jitsu six days
a week
they were like six
and that was that was that was part of
it
let me tell you what I did that's worse
what what's worse is I was like okay
you're also going to compete because
competing makes you better and it gets
worse because then it was oh when I take
you to compete
since I'm the coach I'm gonna put you in
a higher weight class I'm gonna put you
against older kids and you know what if
you lose
look if you lose it doesn't matter
because you're gonna be tougher so so
just go out there do your best if you
lose don't worry about it it's gonna
make you tougher so my daughters go to
compete in jiu-jitsu tournament
jiu-jitsu tournament jiu-jitsu
tournament what happens to them they get
beat they get beat by someone that's
older they get beat by someone that's
heavier is that fun that sucks
what do I think what does idiot think oh
you're getting tougher and so by the
time they were ten it was like I don't
want to do any of this crap anymore and
it got to a point where I was like okay
look this is ridiculous
I realized the mistake that I made and I
just had to back off and and luckily my
son made it through that time period
where he he kept training all the time
and and became very good at jiu-jitsu
and wrestling but with the girls I I
didn't do it right so find a good school
where the jiu-jitsu is fun don't force
it down their throat let me tell you one
more really quick story my son had a
friend who was like you know his running
mate and when he was six years old I
said yeah I will bring your son to
jiu-jitsu let him try it he tried it at
six years old he didn't like he tried it
one time I liked it got choked in the
crying he tried it at age seven hey
we'll try it again didn't like it hated
it tried it at age eight
didn't like it hated it age nine his dad
trained his dad had started training his
he kind of got the
look at like oh that's pretty cool by
the time he was nine and he tried it he
liked it and he liked it because he
liked it and he was then old enough to
make the decision to want to train and
started training hard and he got good
really quick it it wasn't like oh he
missed those four years of training they
didn't make a big difference is my point
they don't make a big difference so the
most important thing you can do as a
parent is make it fun for your kids make
working-out fun make you Jitsu fun make
school fun make these things enjoyable
make let'em win so you don't put them in
positions where they're gonna win and
I'm not saying every time because you do
have to learn how to lose let him learn
to lose when they occasionally let him
learn to lose when they get a loader but
make it fun for him that's the key I'm
gonna eventually get balcony up there
but um I guess you in the back go Jack
oh my questions on the other end of the
spectrum for a police officer I'm a
battalion chief in the fire department
28 years on the department how do I
relate to the 19 year old can you relay
a story that you worked with a 19 year
old new seal and you're trying to get
what to happen I want to develop that
relationship with them you talked about
the relationship above me as a leader
how do I develop that relationship for
the newer people below me the best way
okay when we start talking about
relationships and I mentioned this
earlier what a relationship is a
relationship is trust and that's what a
team is a team as a bunch of people the
relationship that all trust each other
how do I develop trust with someone
that's below me in the chain of command
what I did this is what I did to make
this happen
as a platoon commander as a tasking to
commander as I was in charge of training
is those young guys that are coming in I
gave them responsibility I put them in
leadership positions I remember the
first time I took over a platoon where
the platoon commander got fired and we
had a training operation that night and
I said I said to a platoon chief I said
hey who's a
a squared-away Jew really junior guy and
he gave me a name and I said okay he's
gonna run this mission tonight and the
platoon was like whoa wait what are you
talking about
this kid's gonna run the mission yep and
all of a sudden what's the kid thinking
wow this guy trusts me to do this I'm
gonna do a good job for him and since he
trusts me I'm starting to trust him and
the more you do that the more you push
down that responsibility and you let
people lead and you put trust into them
the more they're gonna trust you as long
as when something does go wrong you
don't chop their head off when something
does go wrong you say hey look let's
let's take a look at it let's see we can
learn from it
and you know what probably my fault cuz
I didn't give you very good guidance so
let's learn from it and we'll try it
again you know what you're gonna run the
same mission tomorrow night I know you
can do this that's how you build that
trust up and that's how you build a team
hand came up quick right there it's
amazing that you can tell who I'm
pointing at Jellico echo thank you for
everything that you've given us
acknowledging that we all have secrets
Jaakko what would you need to see happen
that would change your mind about a run
at public office what let me finish what
would be that trigger event to make you
say okay public office
stand by to get some
[Applause]
a Finnish would say quite frankly you
have a nation of troopers both foreign
and domestic that believe and know that
you're qualified to lead and ready to
lend their support what would it take
there is a line somewhere there is a
line somewhere where where I would feel
like okay the you know the country needs
me it's it's a pretty distant line it's
it's that world is so I don't want to
use the word corrupt but but but because
that's not what I'm talking about not
talking about like that kind of
corruption and there's corruption for
sure
but you know you compare the corruption
that we have to the rest of the world
and it's very nice but there's a
different word that I can't quite
capture there's there's dishonesty
there's I don't mind the chaos um some
selfishness here's what it is I think in
order I like I like when things go wrong
and I know that sounds crazy but one of
my biggest problems is that I get when
things are going good I get really bored
pretty quickly and I just like oh yeah
that's cool oh we hae the business is
doing this like my business like hey
we're doing this and I'm like all that's
awesome we're gonna ready - okay cool
what can I look at next like I get I get
kind of bored when things are going well
and when things are going bad I love it
I really like when things are going bad
and so in the government things don't
get that bad and for me to put my time
and effort towards something all that
you really focus I would get bored very
quickly because you know how to be like
hey you know what we're not doing too
bad and so until there's something bad
that I feel like okay it's time that's
kind of what would wouldn't would make
me roll in that direction it seems like
a miserable life to me it seems like a
miserable life it seems like a life
where you're constantly putting up a
facade and I don't have the desire to do
that you know I never got interested in
going into the CIA or anything like that
because I never wanted to live that kind
of life and it does I'm not saying it's
bad I mean if guys worked with them and
they're awesome but it's just not me and
I don't like to live that way and it
seems like there's a lot of that accept
the fact that if we got into a position
as a nation where things were really bad
and we needed some we needed to take
action then I feel like I would step
into it but man I hope we don't get
there let me put you that way I hope we
don't get there and I don't think we
will but I appreciate that's our porch
and I'm sorry red jacket
first off thank you for everything you
do and then my question is who are your
role models growing up and like what
qualities that they have well my first
legitimate
role models that I looked at and said
okay that's a person that I can emulate
that was when I got to the SEAL Teams up
to that point I was looking I was a
confused kid that was looking at this
you know this person and that person but
I didn't really
but even though even I wasn't confused
enough to be like oh I'm gonna be like
that person and follow what they're
doing I would look at people my god that
seems pretty cool that seems pretty cool
and so it was until I got into the SEAL
Teams and there were some people that
you instantly when I check on the SEAL
team one I'm like that guy's awesome up
get it that that person right there is
awesome I'm gonna do my best to emulate
that person and there was probably five
or seven people at SEAL team one when I
got there that I stole as much as I
could in terms of how to behave and and
that was it you know guy named Master
Chief faculty who was super just ultra
professional and everything and I was
like he's so professional no one can say
anything to him he's a professional like
I'm gonna I'm gonna be like that there
was a couple other there was other guys
that I I'm not unfortunately mastery
faculty died so I'm using his name but
other guys that I just looked at and
said wow that guy's awesome
so mmm I didn't really have like those
kind of role models until I got to the
team's you know
okay Balcon is there anyone on the
balcony microphone style right there up
in the cheap seats
Jaakko
echo thank you for your podcast Jacque I
think we service an echo thank you for
the work that you you work with Jocko
and doing the podcast also thank you to
the men and women the service present
future and past I come from a corporate
environment working doing IT support now
my recent role was where I was
responsible for supporting 40 to 80
people pretty much solo and with that I
had a manager remote you know I had a
good working relationship with him he's
former military so he would tell me to
do certain things with an environment
which I would do but then his manager
would come down and visit and sometimes
give me contradicting situations or
orders so what do you do when you have
your boss Tony one thing his boss your
boss is directly respond
telling you to do something
contradictory yep the pretty
straightforward if my boss's boss comes
to me and tells me to do something I'm
like hey I just want to make sure that
you know that this is what I've been
told to do and then they say yeah I
don't care what that guy says and you go
okay Roger that and then he leaves you
go hey direct boss here's what's going
on boss came down and told me to do this
I'm here I work for you you're my boss
and I want to tell you what's going on
do you want me to proceed or do you want
me to stop I want to keep you informed
here's why I want to I want to do the
right thing and this is what's going on
so just take the information from the
boss the boss's boss got it have you
told you know my boss that nope don't
care okay you don't care fine hey boss
your boss is telling me to do this I
want to let you know what's going on
it's obviously a tenuous situation
because then this guy up above the
higher dive the chain of command my
oldest you didn't do what I told you to
do
hey look I'm just trying to make sure
everyone's informed and and that's the
way that's the way things run smooth
esteem for meeee I'm here to support can
you guys talk to each other so I know
what I'm supposed to be doing down here
but you you got to kind of be the person
that that connects the dots here to the
best of your ability no problem
all right let's say you're in an
organization and you really want to see
it succeed but it's being led by someone
who is not only steering it in the wrong
direction they're doing it deliberately
and you're not really sure if you can
negotiate with them
what would your course my course of
action if there's someone above me in
the chain of command
that's steering us in the wrong
direction I'm gonna do my best to
influence and persuade them if I can't
do that I'm gonna do the best to
mitigate the risk down the chain of
command and this strategic risk I'm
gonna do my best to mitigate it and
while I'm doing that I'm going to try
and inform the other people around that
person of the situation that's going on
I'm gonna I'm gonna build relationships
with the sea oh oh with the CFO with
with the if it's the CEO you're talking
about or if it's the Batali whoever it
is I'm going to build some relationships
with other people so we can get that
person under control the other thing we
have to remember is sometimes at the
bottom we don't understand what the real
strategy is and so my first thing is
like hey boss can you explain to me why
we're doing this because I it doesn't
seem right to me for the following
reasons I want to be able to support
what you're saying can you tell me why
we're doing it describe so sometimes
they say oh yeah it's because of this I
should have explained that sometimes
they say wait a second what do you mean
my strategy is not working down on the
front lines they don't know no one's
telling them so you have to communicate
with them to make sure that that they
understand but to make sure that you
understand what direction you're
supposed to be heading and to make sure
that they understand why it's
problematic on the front lines if all of
that fails and they're just looking
telling you to be quiet and they're
moving forward in something that's going
to really be detrimental to the
organization we got to start trying to
figure out how to flank that person and
and building it building a alliances
with people that can try and get us
going in the right way thank you
sorry and of course there's you know
there's situations where you know
especially in the business environment
like if you're on a ship and the ship is
sinking and you sounded the alarm and
you've tried to you've tried to plug the
holes and you've told everyone and
they're still just staying on board the
sinking ship without making any
Corrections
there are times we gotta go you know
what this ship is sinking and I'm not
gonna stay on it that can happen we
can't you can't save every sinking ship
you can't and you've got to know when
it's time to go okay I'm gonna take the
lessons learned I'm gonna go somewhere
else thank you yes first I want to thank
you because I am a stage-four cancer
survivor and
[Music]
and in my darkest hours that a lot of
people can't comprehend you were there
with me your voice your everything still
to this day I mean discipline equals
freedom is a common phrase in my family
over the most monumental to the most
ridiculous things like letting the dog
out at the same time you know so I want
to thank you for that
with that being said I have at one point
plans my own funeral didn't think I was
gonna be here for my kids you know the
worst part of anybody's dreams you know
nightmares and then should be at the
place where I am right now and not
knowing obviously I'm young and you know
what the future holds nobody's naive how
you've been in those similar positions
just not health-wise but you know facing
death and and everything else how do you
switch from that mindset of like you
said when things are going really bad
I'm freaking awesome
like I kick ass like I really do and
then when things are kind of common like
what do I do now like how am I gonna you
know even when you were just saying like
your last line sometimes I think like
you just speak to me it's so creepy that
yeah like I my last chemo was Friday
I shouldn't be well today but I am
because I knew I had to be here you know
so it's like like
[Applause]
and then when you said that you know at
the end of your podcast that you know
I'm gonna live life I'm going to live my
days how did you get from that
transition from you know possibly I
don't know if I'm gonna come out of this
battle I don't know if I'm gonna come
home to okay I'm here life speaking
great let's party and then in between
like did you have any like how did you
do it how did you get from the darkest
places to brightest places and then
bring everything my problem is is I want
to bring I've learned my lesson like
I've learned what I had to have learned
now and now to bring it forward with me
but not to let it define me if that
makes sense for me and and I actually
gave this answer to Sam Harris because
Sam Harris said to me you know Jocko you
you you you talk about combat as your
fondest memories and it you know the the
best thing that's happened in your life
it's the hype on your life which is all
true and he said but then you talk about
war being awful so which one is it and I
said to him I said have you ever known
anyone that has had cancer terminal
cancer and made it through have you ever
known anyone that that's happened to and
he's like yes and I said when you talk
to them many times they say I'm glad
that this happened to me
number one because it proved I could
take it number two it's better me than
one of my kids and number three now that
I know how dark II can get I truly
appreciate the light in the world
that's what combat is and was for me
that's what it was it was dark and
horrible and I wouldn't wish it on
anyone just like you wouldn't wish
cancer on anyone but if I can give them
a little knowledge a little bit of a
glimpse into what it is just like when
you stand up here people clap when you
said that people are clapping because
they get to see a little bit of it and
they go home tonight and they think what
about that girl what about that girl
she's fighting she's living and I'm
gonna live too
that's why I have cancer that's how I
look at things now I don't pretend to
have the cognitive capacity to
comprehend the mysteries of the world
but maybe you're right and maybe you're
here to let us know that it can get dark
but it will get light again and thank
you
[Applause]
you yes hey Jacko thanks for being here
I've been in the Army for three years
now and for the past year I've been
thinking about putting in a packet for
Special Forces selection so I guess I
just wanted to ask you to talk a little
bit about when you join the SEAL Teams
and what did you do to physically and
mentally prepare yourself and and
generally why did you why did you decide
to join man I wanted to do that since I
was a little kid when I heard that this
I heard that the seals was the toughest
training and that's not the necessarily
true thing all the training is hard
there's the Special Forces the the
MARSOC units the Raiders the Air Force
PJ's and CCC is that it it's everyone's
got their awesome Special Operations
units and the training is all hard and
although when I heard that the seals the
toughest training I said okay that's
what I want to do what do you do to get
ready for you know what you got to do to
get ready for it you you know army guess
what you're gonna be humping a rock
you're gonna be doing forced marches you
got to be able to run you got to be able
to NAV you got to be able to do push-ups
and pull-ups and and dips and rope
climbs and obstacles that's you got to
do you got to train hard you've got to
train as hard as you possibly can and
then you have to tell yourself that
you're not gonna quit no matter what
happens no matter what happens you're
not going to quit
no matter what happens because they're
gonna play a little psychological games
on you like like let's say they go all
he's in good shape he's you know we
can't really touch him physically he's
in really good shape so now you know
what they're gonna do they're gonna say
oh you know you failed this academic
test
you're not smart you're not really smart
enough I mean you seem like a good guy
but you're not really smart enough
you're the kind of you're the kind of
person that would get someone killed
you're gonna make a mistake they're
gonna start attacking you
psychologically or if you're
psychologically strong but you're
physically weak they're gonna be like
hey you're the kind of person that won't
be able to carry me our combat we don't
want you they're just saying that don't
quit that's it
don't quit go get some all right um
think one more yeah we're looking I want
to have some time to hang out sign books
we got to be out of here by 11:00 so
we're getting close
go ahead man front row Jocko think four
uh thank you for speaking tonight just a
quick question I work in a corporation
here in New York and one of the toughest
things with being an analyst here is
just the fact of like when are you
actually escalate or you know which
which kind of feels like defeat but also
at the same time you want to make sure
you live in somebody else know what's
going on so I just want to ask you about
that thank you for me I look at a
problem if I think I can contain the
problem then I'm gonna try and contain
the problem I recognize and I weigh the
risk of if this is wrong what's gonna
happen can I manage that can I control
it can I absorb the impact of that if I
can't absorb the impact of it then I
know it's like okay this I need to bring
this up I need to send this up the chain
ekran if it's something that I know I
can absorb the impact of and I can
explain myself and it will be sense and
it won't have been a strategic loss or a
major error then I'm gonna try and hang
on to it and in the beginning I'm gonna
be I'm gonna err towards sending it up
the chain of command as I start to trust
myself and I get better at my job I'm
gonna hang on to more but again I'm
always gonna weigh is this something
that I can contain or I can absorb if it
goes wrong and if it's something that I
can't hey I'm gonna run it by somebody
so I think it's you just got to weigh
that out and once you weigh that out
make a decision
and live with it alright go one more
here microphone anyone
was there a mic right there
as somebody who's recently recently
proposed to somebody who would like to
spend the rest of my life with somebody
who's married and has from my knowledge
gone away for extensive periods of time
from their partner
what is your tips to building a mortar
proof marriage that's gonna last a long
time
yep the first thing I'll say is you know
you want to develop the you want you you
want to make sure and encourage your
wife to be emo i emotionally independent
emotionally independent cuz there's
gonna be times when you're not around
and if they're dependent on you
emotionally you're not there they're
gonna they're gonna be hurt and they're
not gonna be able to handle it so you
want to help them build that resiliency
where when you're not around they know
how to handle things independently like
the broken water heater and the flat
tire they can do that and you go through
those things you you build that
confidence with them and then also the
emotional independence where what they
have is trust in you that you're gone
but you're coming back and you're gonna
be there for them always that's number
one number two is straight up the
extreme ownership that's what it is when
something is going wrong in your
marriage it's your fault it's your fault
the minute you turn to your wife and you
say you shouldn't have done this you're
wrong and you're taking that
relationship in the wrong direction when
you say hey look I'm trying to figure
out how I made you do what you did I
don't want to let that happen
so taking ownership when things go wrong
that's what you've got to do that's what
you've got to do
thank you awesome awesome
[Applause]
and
with that once again I can't thank you
all enough for coming tonight and I know
that you're just not here tonight I know
that if you're here tonight you're here
all the time you're with us you're
supporting us your support and
everything that we're doing your support
you're representing representing
representing with the store with the
jakka store with the with the origin
here you guys are in the game you're
getting the books and and most important
you're you're listening and you're with
us and the podcasts it's it's a lot of
work it's a lot of work a lot of work
goes into it but I get more out of it
than anyone I get more out of doing this
than anyone and the thing that drives me
to keep doing this is not just what I
get out of it but also that you all are
there and that you all are listening and
that you all are sitting there with us
and that you guys are hearing the same
thing that I'm hearing and you're
learning the same things that I'm
learning
and I know that we're together and I
know that that sounds kind of weird that
sounds kind of crazy but we are we're
together we're hanging out we're moving
forward and together we're stronger
and even though we aren't strong enough
to bring back days and even though we
aren't strong enough to bring back the
sunset at least
we can sit here together
and we can be humbled and mystified by
this life and together
we can go out and we can live it
and I think that's all we've got for
tonight so thanks for coming down and
until next time this is echo and Jocko
thank you